um what's the deal with face miss are
they the same as toner depends on the
ingredients a lot of the time they are
yep thanks beauty and the boy msn I
I think I looked that up once and I
can't remember what I found though but I
will definitely consider that again um
drunk elephant I'm gonna do a full
review on drunk elephant um that's one
of the next things on my like big review
post so my schedule at the moment I'm
trying to do like one review on one sort
of science-based non review post and
alternate those yes I it's in the mix
for the next three ish review posts full
of stress one person rational yeah I I
went way too far fast with that yeah and
I ended up with really really red
irritated nose area so yeah be really
gentle basically treated like trash in
home when you're introducing it matrixyl
yeah so um I did a post on it at some
point oh it was like buried in a review
but I can't entirely remember what I
thought um
ingrown hairs on back same as ingrown
hairs anywhere else exfoliation because
your back skin is a bit thicker and a
bit more resilient than your face skin
you can probably go a bit harder so
things like body brushes body sponges um
and yeah um exfoliant so salicylic acid
um I know polis choice has a spray that
I've been using and you can sort of get
it on your back and then slap it around
a bit I reckon if you just put on your
hand and slap it around it's probably
well it's quite well as well um over
time glycolic acid on your food is there
anything in particular I'd recommend to
restore balance um don't use really
strong active so don't use like anything
that normally would make your skin
tingle or burn so things like um AJ's
salicylic acid vitamin A vitamin C just
avoid all of those and use really
moisturizing products so when my skin is
grumpy I tend to use oils niacinamide
I've been using strategy as liquid gold
but I found that when my skin is super
super irritated it actually stings it a
bit and I think it's just because it's
so watery you know water-based things
tend to sting my skin quite a lot more
if it's like really really sensitized so
I tend to stick to oils and balms for
that um your skin sometimes gets pimple
like red bumps but they usually flat and
never have pus what is this um
unfortunately I'm not a dermatologist I
can't diagnose you but I would recommend
seeing a dermatologist it could be a lot
of different things emotional right okay
um I think if you're in an emotional mad
about your skincare um I don't know I
think sometimes I don't think you really
need to be interest in care - yeah if
you do want to get back into skin care I
think hmm hmm that's a really good
question I'm trying to think of things
things to get out of the skincare right
I mean obviously you don't want to just
buy all the new products um that's
really bad both for your money and
probably not great for getting out of
row right either um maybe just take a
break maybe look at something else if
you still want to stay in skincare maybe
um thanks Devon she um
maybe look at makeup um change your hair
um yeah or even like try to use up your
product so I used to do a lot of project
pants when I first started getting into
skincare and I try to just use up things
and then I tried to combine new things
and when I went back through my stash I
find things that I really like that I
haven't seen for a while and that used
to help me get back into it as well but
um I don't think you really should be
pressured to get back into skincare if
you're not feeling it
if it doesn't make you happy there's not
much of a point I think um hey Leroy um
favorite hydrating facial mask um I
don't really have one I think
sleeping masks so when my skin's really
dehydrated um I'm really basic I put
aqua fall on top of my skincare I've
also been using the Laneige sleeping
mask and the glow recipe watermelon
sleeping mask and they work really well
as well but I think I'm pretty lazy with
masks so um yeah I tend not to really
use the wash off ones that much yeah um
there used to be a really good one but I
think it's been discontinued from
yuriage yuriage it was like this um blue
I think us from the aqua persists line
and I really liked it it was like you
only needed to put it on for 10 minutes
it felt like a gel moisturizer and that
was really good but I think they
discontinued it unfortunately um a good
duration for keeping skin care products
like serums and acne medication before
washing it off in the morning and
evening um I'm not entirely sure what
the evidence is on that but for most
most products the absorption curve tends
to be like this so there's like a little
lag time before it starts absorbing it
hits a peak and then it tails off um
yeah I think for most topical products
like the peak is like not any more than
like two or three hours yeah but I don't
have the exact statistics on that I'm
sure it depends on what the ingredient
is and what the formulation is um yeah
um yeah a lot of it does usually
depending on the product of course it
happens in the first like a little bit
so for when I was looking up how to add
trash known into my routine there there
was a study where I think they found
pretty good results even washing it off
after half an hour compared to leaving
it on the whole time yeah well at least
for acne um cleansing all in hot
cleansing method is it ideal
I think hot cloths they can if your skin
is sensitive they can dry it out they
can make a deal
raided but again depends on your skin
yeah try it if your skin gets dry then
maybe switch to cold maybe get rid of
the cloth yeah
what I recommend adding carrier oil to
already oily skin um what sort of
carrier oil I personally find that my
skin is already quite oily and I use
oils in the evening so things like
rosehip oil and my skin really enjoys
that I don't use it during the day
because then I just look like I'm
melting skin care for eczema um again I
don't know that much about eczema yeah
sorry
but I believe some of the things that
I've seen ceramides although I think it
depends on the type of ceramide as well
and the balance of ceramides with other
skin components i've also even seen like
baking soda baths for eczema and also
bleach baths so I think eczema it's a
it's a it's very different from normal
skin care so um I don't really want to
give you any recommendations right now
without looking it up um
oh yeah so there is a brand which my
friend who does have eczema has
recommended which shares in the group
and that tends to be I think for people
with eczema that's really popular in
Australia
ya know science behind I just just
anecdote recommendations for dark
circles and eye bags um I think the
common advice for that is check for
allergies sleep more maybe drink more
water and see if that helps in terms of
products I think they tend to talk about
thickening the skin under your eyes I
feel like I've read something recently
about dark circles and I just can't
remember what they said sorry um
rosacea I have owned I have a blog post
on rosacea where I interviewed um a
dermatologist called
Estee uh yesterday
Williams I think maybe um yeah so yeah
that's on my blog and she's got lots of
tips so work out what your triggers are
things like hot water sunlight chili
foods I think was one of them you
definitely want to wear a sunscreen as
well reducing a pigmentation yes I've
got the pigmentation video so maybe have
a look at that one is retinol worth that
or am I just wasting time should I
switch to Trajan on um I I think there
are a couple of studies on rational but
there are tons of studies on tretinoin
and so I don't think you are wasting
your time but if you want something
that's more guaranteed then threatenin
is a good option I don't know about
where you are in Australia because we
have a nice public Medicare system which
pays for a lot of prescription
medications it's not that expensive so
the tube I have think it was about 30
ish 25 or 30 dollars for a 30 ml tube
which is I think possibly cheaper than
most rational yeah so depending where
you are I think it might even be like I
think it's a better option for me at
least in Australia smile lines that have
gone red from over exfoliating avoid
actives oils niacinamide if your skin
can handle it um yeah what do I think of
the no pure co-washing movement um I
think for some people's hair works
really well I think they do tend to talk
up a lot of life the whole natural toxic
that sort of not very honest not very
science not very scientific
oh you're 0.025 percent was a hundred
dollars all no that's so expensive where
are you
was that Australia um I got mine from I
got mine as a generic tube from chemist
warehouse and it was yeah it was 30
bucks so if you're in Australia yeah
chemist White House is where it's at um
yes oh yes oh but no poo I think
a lot of it is based on that and I think
if if you're doing it because of that
then it's probably not a great option
but um yeah I think it depends on your
on your hair type on your skin type so
how much oil you have personally I tried
it and it was terrible
I looked really gross and matted and I
everyone says your hair will adjust
after a few weeks and I waited a week
and it was disgusting so I don't want to
try that again
um yeah the red bumps um there's a lot
of things that can be definitely go see
a dermatologist there's this thing
called fungal acne that a lot of people
are talking about from when I've asked
dermatologists about it they say the
best thing to do is to go to them and
use an antifungal like don't try to deal
with it with a skincare routine just go
straight to proper treatment um
homeopathic skincare um it depends on
whether or not it's truly homeopathic so
true homeopathic things are where they
dilute it a whole bunch and it's to the
point where there's probably like one
molecule in it and that's not going to
do anything so it's based on I think
it's like water memory so they say that
the water has has a memory of everything
it's touched which if that was true that
would be really gross because water
touches like a lot of poo um but yeah I
think there's a lot of home so-called
homeopathic things that aren't really
homeopathic so I think there's like
quite a few homeopathic supposedly
homeopathic arnica treatments which
actually have an amount of antiquer in
it that will actually work so I think it
depends on that
um I think zinc and selenium even
without the homeopathic thing they are
good for treating I think I think zinc
I think selenium works for some types of
fungus and zinc can kill bacteria I'm
not sure if it kills other
microorganisms as well but yet those
ingredients can definitely work eczema
psoriasis
again I don't know that much about them
unfortunately yeah I mentioned eczema a
bit earlier I'll repost this on my
Instagram
IG TV channel if I can work out how do
you use it and I'll post it on YouTube
as well if I can work out how to
download it yeah um chemical exfoliation
and moisturiser for sensitive
combination skin so chemical exfoliation
if you've downloaded my chemical
exfoliation guide which is free I think
you just do lab mouthing calm / x4 or /
exfoliate I think both of them will end
up pointing you there um that at the
back of that guide there's a section
where I talk about how to start on um
exfoliation so recommendations for
depending on your skin type depending on
your skin condition and I think in there
there's one for sensitive skin yes I
have a look at that for moisturizers um
if a sensitive combination skin again um
I generally don't like recommending
specific products to people that much
because everyone lives in a different
place
people have different um different
sensitivities so I tend to just try to
recommend ways of working out what
skincare is good for you so like what
ingredients to look for and things like
that rather than a specific product um I
do talk about it in my skincare guide so
the lab muffin guide your basic skincare
um so in that when I talk about like how
to pick a cleanser how to pick a
sunscreen how to pick a moisturizer in
like way too much detail so if you'll if
you want to find out like all of the
stuff about that you can grab a copy of
that um in general for sensitive
combination skin I would avoid things
like fragrances sensitive skin tends to
be sensitive to fragrances combination
skin tends to be a bit tricky um my my
skin is oily combination so it's like
oily here and normal / dry here
depending on how what the weather's like
um and I usually recommend doing like
your moisturizer for normal skin all
over and then no wait sorry stuff that
up
do your moisturizer for the oiliest bits
of your skin all over and they go back
and get a hip heavier moisturizer for
the dry bits so kind of just like I
think there's like a new trend
well so-called trend that everyone's all
the beauty brands have been talking
about which is like multi-masking I
think it's their way of trying to sell
you more than one mask but it's like use
different masks for different areas of
your skin so kind of like that before
moisturizer um but I think it's a bit
better for moisturizer cuz I use the
whole thing in summer and then as winter
comes along you just add more and more
of the thicker moisturizer on your
cheeks and then when it goes back to
somebody's like like slow that down and
so overall you it doesn't cost that much
more and it's not that much more effort
either am i enjoying my purple I am
loving my purple um am i washing an
early in cold water no it's winter here
so I I cannot but I have been doing a
cold rinse and that was horrific
I've only washed it once so I'm trying
to wash it as little as possible because
it was pretty expensive
um and I do really like this color but I
am actually looking forward to having
this color fade out because I'm planning
to just die tons of different colors
really excited about that I've wanted to
have like pale pastel hair for about ten
years
um and I finally found the time and the
money and the right hairdresser as well
to do it and I'm so happy I've had it
yeah it's it's so exciting for me what
brand of niacin might is the best um I
don't know um
for products that have been really
popular I think the most popular one is
that I can think of off the top of my
head is probably strategy a liquid gold
there's also the ordinary is niacinamide
and zinc but I've also heard from a lot
of people that it breaks them out yeah
um can i push for can you you the royal
you purge from masters like 2% be hhas
and vitamin C um ba and AJ's yes
so generally how purging works I've got
tons more info on this on my purging
versus breakup video generally purging
happens if
your skin cycle is speeding up so it's
basically like just putting your skin
into overdrive everything works faster
including breaking out um so err chase
and BHA will speed up your skin turnover
bottom see does not
so technically vitamin C shouldn't make
you purge however low pH does help your
skin exfoliate so if your skin wasn't at
the right pH before now you're putting
like low pH stuff on it and it's like
more in the correct pH then it could
potentially be I'm going faster yeah so
potentially just because of the pH but
the ingredient itself I don't see itself
shouldn't be causing purging um hi
Hannah
how to get rid of blackheads and
whiteheads um depends on what you've
tried
I think exfoliation is one really good
way and depends on how severe it is so I
think exfoliation hydroxy acids are a
really great option if it's really
really bad and it is stressing you out a
lot maybe see a dermatologist
so when um so dermatologists now are a
little bit more likely to prescribe like
a weaker course of accutane as well for
that if it's really really distressing
yeah but there's lots of options don't
don't stress out um maybe try the
hydroxy acids first and see how that
goes
um can skin get used to certain products
can can use the same moisturizer for
years and years without changing it um
can skin get used to certain products
hmm I have heard this one um I know I
enjoyed it and I've lost all the
questions I'll just scroll up on you um
I don't really know um
can your skin get you so I think your
skin does adjust to moisturizer but
whether or not it stops working um yeah
I don't know I think if your skin does
seem to stop work like if it doesn't to
stop working on your skin then yeah
maybe
change but there are lots of people who
have been using the same products for
years and years and it seems to still be
working for them so I don't think it's
like a universal rule your skin does
change over time as well so I think
sometimes maybe if a skincare product
stops working for you maybe your skin is
changing and not just your skin's
getting used to the products maybe
you're aging maybe your hormones aren't
working exactly the same maybe it's just
an overall change in climate maybe like
I don't know your waters changing yes
sir I think it's really hard to say um
what are the causes and solutions for
blind pimples pretty much the same as
for blackheads and whiteheads I think so
exfoliation I'll wait
blind pimples so the really really deep
ones like hormonal pimples um I don't
know I wish I knew
I've been trying out lots of different
things and I think the problem with
trying to work out what to do is just
the fact that when you do get a giant
blind pebble I've got one here at the
moment it's a bit hard to see it's that
you can't really try things on it really
objectively because you've only got one
you can't really compare to anything
else um I got true once right next to
each other and I got really excited
because I thought maybe I could compare
things but I couldn't see a difference
um the things I tend to try which may or
may not work and I can't even tell if
it's working for me is salicylic acid so
I have a full percent DHA treatment from
Paula's Choice I had a nine percent when
I don't know where it went
um yes if BHA my reasoning all of this
is like not scientifically verified it's
just like my best guess
I think PHA might be able to penetrate
better into the port than something like
AJ um hydrocolloid bandages I've heard
some people say that using a
hydrocolloid bandage will suck it out
even if it's a blind pimple I don't know
how much I believe that but it is
something I've tried um
neem oil I tried that ages ago it stinks
it smells a bit like fried garlic or
onion um what else have I tried um
[Music]
heat my sister swears by a rice sock
which is basically just like a weed bag
but rice like she puts the rice in a
sock and then microwave it and puts it
on um some people use cold as well yeah
um I think if it's like really deep
hormonal acne there are treatments for
it things like spironolactone I haven't
gotten to the point where I'm want to
try that yet but yeah blind pimples it's
a bit of a mystery to me something that
will definitely work for blind people if
it's like a really important event the
next day like if it's if you're getting
married the next day and you have a
giant like massive pimple on your face
um you can get a steroid injection from
the dermatologists and that apparently
makes it shrink like immediately um
[Music]
lines on the neck so generally it's like
aging things so things like sunscreen
Trisha Nolan yeah those are probably the
main things one thing is when you're
aging it's not just the skin so those
things will treat the skin but if you
want to treat the deeper things so
things like sagging um unfortunately
that's not just the skin that's the
muscle and the bone as well that also
changes as you grow older so those
things can't be treated with treasure
Nolan or sunscreen yeah um I think
there's been some like some research on
things like facial exercises so if you
exercise it then the muscles don't wear
down as quickly or they stay plumped up
for longer
I believe that's also how the
microcurrent devices are meant to work
but I think the only really guaranteed
thing is like face lifts and things like
that
fillers um can you add ascorbic acid and
powder to your moisturizer do you have
to dilute first or can you add it
directly to the moisturizer um I think
it depends on the moisturizer you can I
personally add it directly because I'm
lazy and there is a study where they put
they put powder
vitamin C on the skin and it absorbed
and worked so I don't think you really
need true the risk you run though is if
you have like a little grain of vitamin
C sitting on your skin and then your the
way it dissolves is it's probably
dissolving through like trans epidermal
water loss so when your water evaporates
from your skin and starts dissolving the
little vitamin C crystal it's gonna like
basically form a hot spot and if you
have a hot spot and vitamin C vitamin C
dissolves the pH is actually pretty high
sorry pretty low lower than the 3 ish
that most vitamin C serums are at so you
might get like a little chemical burn
and are like it's gonna it might sting
it might not be great for your skin
either if like if you have a little
chemical burn it could even cause
pigmentation so I think that's the risk
you run for most people it's probably
fine so there are lots of products that
are just powdered vitamin C in a base so
things like um what's that brand the
brand with all the white packaging
indeed labs they have think it's called
like vitamin C 24 or something that's
basically just powdered little bits of
vitamin C in a silicone base and most
people are fine with that so yeah I
think it depends on how much water you
have in your moisturizer how sensitive
your skin is how big the crystals of
your vitamin C are and how easily they
dissolve so there is a slight risk but
um yeah can you introduce different bio
diluting it with moisturizer yes yes you
can um one of my thoughts on the foreo
luna um I have a Luna play plus I
personally don't really enjoy using
exfoliation tools um I don't know why I
think they just don't feel as effective
on my skin as a peeling gel I love
peeling gels
that's probably basically it um yeah
that's my main thoughts I think I have
seen a lot of the claims that the fari
Lunas it things like um
sending your skincare deeper into the
skin and stuff like that I'm not sure
how much I believe that yeah can you put
serum under rationale yes you can so you
can yeah you can putting the serum on
the under the rationale will dilute it
will probably make it less irritating it
could potentially make it a little bit
less effective but I don't think it
makes a massive difference yeah so if
you're if you're finding that the
rationale is too irritating I think
putting serum under it is a good idea or
moisturizer honored as well um how to
minimize losing products on the pillow
um probably just sleep on your back um
yeah I don't know how else you could
minimize it really sorry um it's a
normal for your skin to get red and
itchy when using aperture um I think it
is it's not oh so epidural
i from memory it's like benzoyl peroxide
and they're definitely um it's possible
that you have an allergy definitely
check if you have an allergy benzoyl
peroxide allergies
drue happen and red and itchiness is a
thing but it's also quite irritating so
it could also be irritation so
definitely check on that have I tried
lumic an off-label to try to grow brows
and lashes yes I have I tried Kara frost
which back in the day it was like the
most popular thing to do you order it
off a dodgy Indian pharmacy it was like
all day chemists though all these
warnings about how you had to not use
your credit card you have to get a
special credit card so that they
wouldn't steal your information um yeah
um I did try it it worked really well
it made my lashes really really long I
believe the main side effect is if it
gets into your eyes it can make your
eyes go dark I don't know if I recommend
like using prescription things and
ordering things from um Toshi pharmacies
it was a long time ago I was very young
um yeah but it does it is one of the
things that works really well
um I believe it's one of the few things
that has clinical trials on it so the
active ingredient is by matter Proust
um what lipstick am I wearing um it's
this lipstick I've rediscovered ever
since I've dyed my hair purple its face
of Australia glossy lip crayon in pilot
mode um yeah it's pretty cheap it's they
used to stop it in price like in price
line I think they now only stock face of
Australia in big W or Kmart one of those
places but yeah this thing it's really
really good it does move around a lot
but it's super moisturizing scientific
articles about dehydration after using
sheet masks for more than twenty minutes
um I can't actually remember I feel like
I've looked this up yeah sorry about
that
can you use all based moisturizer under
sunscreen um you can so there is a oh
there's only 9 seconds remaining
ah I'll come back